I'm sorry to report that the new cold
war between China and the United States
has reached the pandas these very cute
lovely giant pandas are famous and they
are down the street at the zoo in
Washington DC and they have been since
the 70s when Richard Nixon went to China
and as a gesture of friendship China
gave us two pandas I am pleased to
accept the precious gift of the Panda
from the government of the People's
Republic of China we've had these two
pandas at our Zoo for the last 50 years
and now now they're going home forever
China practices Panda diplomacy giving
pandas to countries around the world
that they're friends with if you make
China mad they might take away your
pandas and that's potentially what's
going on here no one knows exactly why
they didn't renew the lease for the
pandas to stay at our Zoo but many
experts think that it's because of the
rising tensions between the United
States and China so if you're here in DC
and you love pandas you've got a few
more months to say goodbye